I've been making videos for a lot of
years and whether it's for Fox or the
New York Times or for the Channel music
is easily one of the biggest things that
changes how a video feels music like
this
if you've been around for a while you've
definitely heard me say things like this
before that thing that inspires me is
music so I started working with this guy
that's a good sound this is Tom Tom Fox
we've been collaborating since 2018 and
now five years later Tom is the
full-time composer here in the studio he
makes the music for every one of the
videos why does a small independent
journalism Production Studio on YouTube
need a full-time composer that's absurd
yes it is absurd and it's completely
necessary and it is what makes these
videos Shine from the Europe video to
the Putin videos the videos about
Doritos every one of these has a
different tone and feel because we
crafted music that fits for that story
well there's now a place where you can
listen to this music it is called The
Listening Room it's totally free up on
YouTube right now you can listen to it
while you work while you study while you
work out see in The Listening Room